in the wasteland can anyone hear you
scream well the swallow raid isn't super
mutant so probably anyway as one imgur
user discovered one man's junk I should
probably rephrase that is another man's
niche reference from 70s movie alien I'm
your news officer Lucy James in charge
of this space faring GS news update
there is a ton of junk in Fallout ball
but going forward you might want to
double-check those random scraps before
you drop or trash them imgur user 1 x
took a closer look at a [ __ ] sensor they
found in a Bostonian wasteland hut and
thought they'd do a little research
after observing something that seemed
random on the back the sensor after
finding a string of random numbers and
letters see em dash 8 8 B 1809 246 onine
for the curious they ended up finding
this screen cap from the movie alien one
time said it feels really rewarding and
encourages me to explore more if you
want to find the alien easter egg
yourself 1 x also provided pictures of
where to find it in the wasteland now
this easter egg is probably not gonna be
the last one that we find in fallout 4
gives a walk Rita Cliff Bleszinski
tweeted that a fallout would develop a
friend of his said that there are more
numbers hidden in the game maybe the
numbers and a button to press every
hundred and eight minutes I mean
probably not but I wouldn't put it past
Bethesda have you uncovered any other
easter eggs in fallout 4 yet and what's
your favorite gaming egg of all time let
me know in the comments section below or
come by me on Twitter I'm at least see
James games this is lucy video producer
for gamespot signing off
you